tonight it is my tremendous honor to be
present a long over due moment as Wes
Studi becomes the very first Native
American to receive an Academy Award
when I think about where I think my god
what a face that face that is etched
with history with experienced character
dignity every emotion Under the Sun that
face that tells so many stories all at
once it's carved from a life lived to
the full West doesn't do anything by
halves some of that life has been spent
there's an actor some as a musician a
combat veteran and activist is many
things he is multi-talented he's also a
linguist and an expert horseman I got to
see that expertise when we worked
together on Scott Cooper's hostiles West
portrays West portrays a dying Cheyenne
war chief and I'm a reluctant US cavalry
officer tasked with escorting him from
his forced imprisonment in New Mexico
back to his tribal Montana homeland you
might be thinking that this was yet
another romantic comedy by Scott Cooper
but I assure you it wasn't we were at
extreme elevation with torrential rains
lightning strikes that seemed to have a
personal vendetta against us
rattlesnakes galore and worst of all
other bloody actors to deal with
throughout and Wes was present with a
good laugh an unrepeatable joke right a
lot of those or a kind smile it's just
when you least expected it but most
welcomed it we spoke a fair bit of
dialogue in Cheyenne a daunting task but
Wes made it look effortless as he did
with his riding he is at one with the
horse which believe me is not common
even on a Western set it's actually
quite entertaining if you ever get the
chance to see actors trying to pretend
that they've you know spent many years
on horses take that opportunity over the
course of his career Wes has spoken more
than two dozen different native
languages on screen not just a word here
and there but lengthy linguistically
challenging conversations
in dozens of languages whether it be
Pawnee Cheyenne his native Cherokee or
Comanche which does it with ease how
many of us can say that his
extraordinary linguistic ability isn't
limited simply to existing language for
James Cameron's Avatar West was a
language consultant working alongside
the production linguist to create words
for a new language called Navi he is
passionate about the preservation of
native languages and communities he
serves as spokesman for both the
indigenous language Institute and the
partnership with Native Americans but
for always his practical skill with
words it's still how he uses them that
makes him such a brilliant actor his
performance is a nuanced his characters
are rich truthful three-dimensional and
when they're based on historical figures
they are painstakingly accurate I've
seen firsthand the care that Wes takes
to make sure every detail whether that
be props wardrobe weapons art direction
that it's all properly attended to it's
clear that Wes is in possession but
brilliant mind and prodigious talent but
more importantly as an artist he has had
a profound influence on the perception
of his people when we think of Native
Americans in film his some of the most
distinctive performances that we all
remember his work is part of a
remarkable and necessary canon but when
we think of masterful canons it's
important to remember that they reflect
only those who've had the opportunity to
participate too few opportunities in
film on both sides of the camera have
gone to native or indigenous artists we
were roomful of people who can change
that it is imperative that we do
yes thank you so much for asking me to
present this to you also I mean really
having me followed joy Harjo
US poet laureate I mean what an
anticlimax I apologize for that what
cruelty to everybody involved but anyway
on behalf of myself the Academy and
moviegoers across the world I would like
to thank you for your work and
congratulate you on tonight's honor if I
were as talented as you I would say in a
couple of dozen languages but I'm not so
you'll have to settle for it in English
wes is my immense privilege to present
you with this Academy Award